I know you've made a discovery have you
memorized the three numbers I have it
you don't know I don't know I'm sorry I
didn't even notice I learned from
somebody else's posting that one of the
numbers is prime so notice that we found
three integers whose cubes some 233 this
number was immortalized in a paper by
Bjorn Putin he pointed out that if you
want to solve that problem for the
number 29 it's really easy so 29 is 27
plus 1 plus 1 if you move a bit up the
number line and and you ask about 30 we
know a solution for that but the numbers
are in the billions and that was only
discovered in 1999 at Andrews I
understand there are some numbers that
you will never find one for that's right
so if your number if you divide it by 9
and you get a remainder of 4 or 5 then
we know you can't do it so you made a
brilliant video with Tim browning on
this at the time it was an unsolved
problem there have been some attempts to
prove that this number isn't on the list
but those attempts of failed and well
I've just sold it I first saw the video
you know around the time he came out and
I thought a bit about it but didn't get
very far
it was actually the follow up video on
74 I think that was made a couple of
years ago but I only saw it last month
and that spurred me to think more about
it and I got hooked over this last
number here 74 he's actually represented
as a sum of three cubes maybe I'll show
you something so about these numbers so
I've got sad his paper here so if you
look at the end of the paper he's put
all of the numbers below a thousand for
which we don't know the answer now
here's a test Brady do you notice
anything about these numbers peculiar
okay if you stare at it a while you
might notice that they're all divisible
by three okay and if we take this a step
further and divide them by nine actually
this is a good plug for you're casting
out nines video okay so this one has
remainder six when you divide it by nine
this is another six another six starting
to see a pattern here
it breaks with this one this is
remainder three okay this is remainder
three this is remainder three and so on
and so forth so it turns out they all
have remainder three or six when you
divide them by nine that's not an
accident so as tim explained in one of
the follow-up videos
it matters what the remainder is we need
to buy nine we know that if you get
remainder four or five then actually
there's no solutions at all
so as the same kind of analysis shows
that if you get remainder three or six
it's possible but only just
it means the solutions for these numbers
are likely to be more sparse okay and
that's what ends up making them hard to
find the modern conjectures every one of
these numbers they'll be infinitely many
solutions it's just they're extremely
sparse and so you know the first one can
be enormous as we've seen we want to
solve an equation like X cubed plus y
cubed plus Z cubed equals say 33 and
we're looking for solutions where all
the numbers are below some bounce okay
so say absolute value of X absolute
value of y and absolute value of Z are
all below some bounds say B okay so
imagine B is a million or something now
on the face of it this is a
three-dimensional problem okay we've got
three variables to solve for x y and z
and if you just went through all
possibilities up to B that's somewhere
on the order of B cubed numbers to check
I said you can imagine B as a million to
put things in perspective your smart
phone can do a million things in the
blink of an eye a million calculations
like this okay but if I say a million
cubed all right
that's in the realm of possible but very
expensive to do on modern computers so
this is actually very wasteful so it's
not hard to see that in this search
range there's loads of places where
there's no point in looking okay so if I
imagine that XY and z are all positive
and large and of course there's no way
that the sum of their cubes is going to
be a small number okay so already
there's there's big parts of the search
range that you that you can cut out if
you take this idea to its logical
conclusion it's it's not hard to see how
to get from B cubed down to B squared
this was realized pretty early on even
the very first computer investigations
that people did in the 50s on this they
had algorithms that were basically
quadratic I would work in in this time
now that wasn't improved on for about 40
years and then a guy called no Mel keys
and Harvard actually in a news group
posting he proposed another algorithm
which is pretty amazing actually
it manages to get down from B squared to
basically be to the one power so e to
the one plus something very small and
it's basically what enables us to go to
the ranges that we are today you know 10
to the 15 10 to the 16 it turns out that
LG's algorithm is most efficient when
you're looking for a solution for lots
of numbers as we work for a while but
you can see we're getting down to a
pretty short list at this point so I
started to think well maybe there are
other approaches that we could look at
my approach uses more algebra so what
I'll do is I'll take this equation and
then we'll move the Z cubed over to the
other side okay so that gives us X cubed
plus y cubed equals 33 minus Z cubed
this is now X plus y x squared minus XY
plus y squared equals 33 minus Z cubed
okay now why have I done that well we
have this factor that that we know is
there okay I'm gonna give us a name I
call it sandy say for a divisor all
right
now one more step and I promise we're
getting at the end of the algebra let's
divide both sides by D okay so I'm gonna
have on the left side just x squared
minus XY plus y squared
all right side 33 minus e cubed over D
now it probably looks like I've made
things a lot more complicated right
we started with three variables and now
we've got four but I want you to imagine
for a moment that we know the values of
Z and D or maybe we have some guests for
them well that means that everything on
the right hand side is something I know
or I can compute on the left hand side I
have a quadratic equation with two
unknowns now as everybody knows if
you've got two variables to solve for
you need two equations I've got one here
but there's another one that I used
implicit leave it didn't write down and
that's this one so X plus y is equal to
D all right so now I've got two
equations two unknowns we know how to
solve this or more to the point if I
guess values for Z and D I can tell
pretty easily whether there are
corresponding integer values of x and y
okay and this is the idea we just go
through all possible values for Z and D
and see if there's any corresponding x
and y and now that again sounds like it
should be something like B squared right
because there's two variables but the
key is
once I've picked a value for Z the
values for 4d are actually quite
restricted because they have to be
divisors of this number 33 minus Z cubed
and there aren't many of those so once
you've worked out Z you can work out all
the possible values for D pretty easily
and then just try all of them I've
glossed over a few things here so in
actual practice you do it the other way
around you you go through values of D
and then you work out Z from there but
yeah this is the idea in a nutshell so I
use lots of computers actually there are
a few separate clusters and the the
computation that found the solution was
the big computer at the University of
Bristol blue crystal phase 3 this
happened way faster than I was expecting
so I started this I thought I was in for
man you know 6 months of computation my
initial fear was that nothing would turn
up and then I'd have to justify why I
was using so many CPU cycles ok as soon
as I started using a computer within a
few days it found the solution the bound
I used was 10 to the 16 so that's 1
followed by 16 zeroes I had actually
planned to do 10 to the 17 ok but but
one pops out before I expected it you'll
see here at 9:05 in the morning on
February 27th so this was running on 512
CPU cores and at the same time one of
them went through one of these values of
D actually this is the number D in the
middle here I don't know what that is
887 trillions ok it turns out to be a
prime number from that it did all of
this algebra and I found the
corresponding values of XY and Z and
here they are the computer found the
solution at 9:05 which is just after I
dropped my kids off at school and as I
was walking to the University and I
noticed it around 9:30 when I got to my
office
no I didn't ring it to send me an email
so I had to check it makes it more fun
because there's an element of you know
uncertainty and the thing how often were
you checking
we each already checking like every hour
or you check once a day or once a day or
something like that as soon as I saw the
file was there I knew that it had a
solution of course then I checked it you
never a hundred percent sure that you
know you haven't made a mistake
somewhere so I put these numbers into
the computer and cube them and add in
the
and about 33 what did that feel like I
did a jump for joy yeah yes yes you made
an excellent point in the first video on
this which is that we can't hope to
solve this by just computing more okay
cuz there's always another number for us
the next one is 42 so 42 the new the new
white whale is 42 is the new 33 yeah
that's right
and so if we just look at the numbers up
to a hundred so let me say K less than
or equal to 100 there's 22 numbers in
that range that give a remainder of four
or five when you divide by nine so
they're possible so they're not possible
that's right we know the answer for
those and they're not possible
that leaves seventy-eight numbers to
account for the very first computer
investigation of this was done way back
in 1954 that's pretty early as these
things go
and they found 69 solutions were 69 out
of the 78 well of course that's not the
end of the story so computer technology
advanced rapidly from there and within a
decade
another group of mathematicians but they
were disappointed because they found
only one more despite going about 20
times further in terms of the variables
but remember they were using a quadratic
time algorithm so it's a about 400 times
as much work so it's impressive from an
engineering standpoint yeah they found
only one more solution so they took this
as evidence that there probably aren't
any more
they hedge their bets a little bit they
didn't say no more solutions but they
said that not all of the remaining eight
candidates would have solutions that was
the prevailing wisdom for a while for
over twenty years now we think that
conjecture is wrong okay things have
kind of turned around but it wasn't
until the early 90s that Heath Brown
said we'll hang on so if there are
solutions they're likely to be extremely
sparse in fact he does some calculations
and he shows that for some of these
small numbers you would expect the the
numbers from one solution to the next to
increase by a factor of millions okay so
that means you know each time you find
one you're gonna have to work a million
times harder to find the next one so the
fact that you've that you've expanded
the search range by 20 and not found
anything is not by itself very good
evidence that there's nothing what have
you found
and so people looked again from 1991
to this year 19 we've found solutions
for seven out of the eight there's only
one number left 42 is the only one left
below 100 so we have not completely
disproved their conjecture from 63 but
it's looking pretty good for Heath
Browns yeah counter conjecture and
review got the computer looking for 42
no I already looked for 42 in the same
range and nothing turned up but yeah
maybe we shouldn't stop there that's
right yeah
there's a definite purpose here because
this is a problem where we're not even
sure or it's not even obvious what the
right conjecture should be okay and
that's evidenced by the fact that the
conjecture has changed in our lifetimes
does that mean you know a mathematician
like you instead of just picking them
off one by one with the computer yeah
should you be sitting down and trying to
come up with a rigorous proof I mean
what's the point of just picking these
off one at a time yeah well so of course
other people are working on that sort of
thing and we do have theoretical
evidence that supports the conjecture to
some people think though that this
problem is actually undecidable so it
might be that we never have a proof and
this is as close as we can come okay so
but with each one of these sovereign
candidates that we finds that gives
another nail in the coffin of this idea
that there aren't any more solutions so
it's so in a way knocking off these
stubborn candidates I've never heard
that term before I can have knocking off
these stubborn candidates is almost
you're giving hope to the people who are
actually trying to come up with the
rigorous proof yeah yeah so it's looking
pretty good for heath brown's conjecture
so probably this conjecture is true and
we can we can ask you know can we prove
it
what's that conjecture in a nutshell
what is the conjecture so every one of
these numbers that doesn't have
remainder four or five when you divided
by nine will have infinitely many
solutions and infinitely many ways of
writing it as a sum of three cubes did
you did you tell your family about this
did you tell you why yes what'd she say
she was wondering why she should care
yeah so I even told the children and
they were excited and I run a maths Club
in my kids primary school and we did a
unit on cubes and adding up cubes and
talk
about this I showed your video you know
are you gonna do with this number you're
gonna get it tattooed on your alright no
as you saw I don't even remember it
better you have to memorize that would
be a good party trick next time I come I
want you to have memorized it come back
to these ones but the next eligible one
is this number 33 and in fact we still
don't know an answer to that one so
we've not yet been able to find any
integers which when you sum their cubes
you get 33